[Music]
[Music]
here are three different ways that the
monster wagner from stranger things
season 4 can be killed
let's start a little bit with an intro
into the monster and then head on to the
main topic
so subscribe and let's get on with this
monster content
wagner was a very powerful dark entity
and is the main boss of the upside down
dimension as of now but he wasn't really
from that place to begin with wagner was
a human male named henry creel that had
tremendous psychic power in the past
after having a fight with 11
she defeated him and sent him to the
upside down dimension and there he
stayed slowly growing and transforming
into a grotesque monster while henry
creel was a normal human and physical
makeup this monster now known as wagner
is dark and deformed his epidermal layer
is filled with tendrils and tentacles
that wrap around his body like overgrown
tumorous roots his face bears a skeletal
appearance and one of his hands has an
overgrown claw
and that he uses to drag out the souls
and life force of his victims but he is
still not all powerful and can be heard
so let's see what are the ways that he
could be killed
number one eleven kills him with her
immense psychic abilities yeah for those
who have seen season four then you have
already seen eleven in her young age
unleashing her powers on the much older
henry creel the one who would become
wekner in the series well ever since
then wagner has grown more powerful and
with him tapping power from the upside
down dimension
he would be very hard to kill but then
again 11 is on her way towards unlocking
her full potential as well with the help
of her papa and others so we would
probably see another showdown between
these two psychic behemoths in the end
and either one of them or both will die
if the show would come to a close this
season then
that would probably happen otherwise 11
would survive the encounter and wagner
would probably go kaput but the problem
here is can 11 really do it
number two nuking the upside down
dimension we have seen the demagogue in
flinching from fire the mind flare being
vulnerable to it and there is absolutely
no flames in the other dimension at all
which means all these monsters
weaknesses as extremely hot temperature
and what weapon creates the biggest
flame ever well either a thermobaric
bomb or most definitely a nuke
let's look at this scenario monsters are
unleashed into the planet bullets don't
stop them but explosives and flames do
then the most convenient and most
logical way to bring an end to all the
madness is to nuke hawkins
and when that's done either enter the
portal into the upside down and manually
detonate a high yielding thermonuclear
warhead anywhere in the vicinity of the
hive mine or simply put it near wagner
the nuclear explosion with millions of
degrees in the fireball stage would
completely vaporize everything in its
path mineflayer wagner that old house
everything
but the main problem here them here is
how to securely put a bomb there and set
it to detonate without being killed
first by the bats or the demogorgons or
you know being tortured by wagner
through his mind control number three
explosive implant this self-destruct
device should it ever be tampered with
when inserted in the neck would go boom
just like that in just like the scenario
in suicide squad
and that is how the organization got
henry creel under their control and this
is one technique that can kill him but
now as wagner it would be near
impossible to insert another implant
inside his body but then again it's near
impossible not absolutely impossible
remember when max
was with wekner in the mindscape she
fought back and with a bit of
distraction she managed to injure him
ripping a part of his neck with her hand
so if that can happen a combined sneak
attack by the characters with a little
help from someone with maybe marksman's
skills can definitely shoot an explosive
implant chip into wegner and the
resultant explosion would vaporize his
head putting an end to the monsters in
essence it means eliminating the hive
mind but the problem here is wagner is a
powerful telepath and can clearly see a
trap in front of him and also he could
quickly kill them before the plan is
even initiated anyway that is what we
think are the three ways that wagner
could be killed and with that we come to
the end of it so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the mind cue family but most
of all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam